I became interested in this phenomenon
of Constraints inspiring creative
outbursts and if you look at the last
century there were three really profound
examples of that I would say the
earliest that I found incredibly
interesting was the limit of the speed
of light leading Einstein to the theory
of relativity where a lot of other
scientists wanted to remove the limit
they wanted to say there is no limit to
the speed of light that doesn't make any
sense that's impossible
Einstein actually despite the word
relativity adhere to a very strict
absolute and that absolute was the speed
of light he took that to be his guiding
constraint and by sticking to it rigidly
he said I'll give up anything else but
the speed of light the constancy of the
speed of light and by doing so he gave
up on the absolute nature of space and
time so I mean that's just much harder
to let go of intuitively and a much
greater violation of our common sense
but it was right and so this was an
example where this tight constraint led
to a creative outburst you know from
this one constraint you could trace the
line not only to the relativity of space
and time but the expansion of the
universe the existence of black holes
the idea that the entire space has a
shape all of these things burgeoned
from this really tight constraint
another great example is a Heisenberg
uncertainty principle
so Heisenberg begins to believe that we
can't precisely know the location of a
particle and its motion and its momentum
and this seems to violate what we
believe that things objectively exist
that there should be no such limit but
he takes it very seriously he doesn't
just say oh it's often cast in this way
oh we disturb a particle when we observe
it therefore we can't also know its
momentum
once we've located it because in the
process of measuring it we've somehow
disturbed it that's not really true it's
much deeper than that Heisenberg took
very seriously that this was profound
that in some sense the particle doesn't
have a location or a momentum that in
some sense the particle doesn't really
exist in the old-fashioned way we used
to think it existed like a marble exists
you know so by taking it that much more
seriously it leads to the discovery of
the deeper phenomenon of quantum
mechanics and that incredibly strange
world that even though we don't actually
understand it even today we we verify
experimentally over and over again it's
the most well tested paradigm in all of
physics and yet it's the one we
understand the least my third example
would be go dils
limit theorem so the great mathematician
Hilbert sent out a call to all
mathematicians just to confirm that all
mathematical facts could indeed be
proven within the context of mathematics
it wasn't the case that he wanted every
infinite proof that's obviously
impossible he just wanted the proof that
they the proofs exist if it seems like a
sort of metal level question it is it's
a meta level question can we prove that
all facts are knowable is a simpler way
of saying it and gödel comes along in
the 1930s and proves that even in the
context of something as basic as
arithmetic that there are facts among
the numbers that can never be proven to
be true or false
there are literally facts we can never
know in the context of mathematics and
that was a real blow to this idea of a
mathematical theory of everything we've
recovered from that blow then and it
turned out to have profound consequences
and the profound consequence was the
invention of the computer and AI so you
can trace Turing's creation of the idea
of a machine that can think directly to
his work on the limit theorems and the
fact that there are certain things we
can never know and that limit is severe
and from that thinking about that
limit he was able to imagine how to
mechanize thought and begin to think
about making machines that think and
begin to think that we're just machines
that think and therefore there could be
an artificial intelligence just like
there's a biological intelligence